there is currently a massive sale going
on for the nabla capsule 2 r2d2 limit
edition so please go show them your
support and you can pick one up for only
4.99 link to that is also in the video's
description good luck in the giveaway
and enjoy a video preview of the product
thanks guys
i have placed information vital to the
survival of the rebellion into the
memory systems of this r2 unit my father
will know how to retrieve it this is the
nebula capsule 2 star wars r2d2
projector with this limited edition
model it features the r2d2 design and
for the startup sound it even includes
the voice of r2 which is pretty damn
cool this mini projector has android tv
9 installed so you can enjoy over 5000
apps including youtube disney plus
twitch netflix and more this means you
can watch thousands of movies like
revenge of the sith
or even your favorite content creators
on youtube
[Applause]
there are several other uses for this
device if you wanted to you could use it
as an extra monitor for your pc for
gaming or what i also like to use it for
a bluetooth speaker
i gotta say the sound quality really
blew me away it sounded a lot better
than i was expecting and this was nicely
complemented with the hd picture overall
i'm really happy with the product and i
definitely think people will be
satisfied with it so the links to their
website and products will be in the
description so please make sure you go
check that out thanks for watching